[Music]
because it is in this way positive that
the validation of duty as something
absolutely sacred falls outside of
actual consciousness
this latter accordingly stands all
together on one side is the imperfect
moral consciousness just as in regard to
its foreknowledge it knows itself then
as a consciousness whose knowledge and
conviction are imperfect and contingent
similarly in regard to its willing it
knows itself as a consciousness whose
purposes are affected with sensuousness
on account of its unworthiness therefore
it cannot look unhappiness as necessary
but as something contingent and can
expect it only as a gift of grace
paragraph 608 is another one of these
short little punchy paragraphs in a
whole sequence talking about the
relationship between these two sides of
moral consciousness and here we're
looking at the actual or real vieja
moral consciousness of a voice sign
being aware of something and he says
that because it is in this way posited
that the validation of duty though the
galton does fix right fickt is is duty
Galton could be validation it could be
signing worth to it so what's the
implication here of the language that
that we're not entirely getting what the
value or worth of duty in fact is or if
we are getting that right it's kind of
accidental we're in a certain sense
estranged from absolute duty it was a
very interesting thought to ponder over
so he says it's it's positive that the
validation as something absolutely
sacred something holy right it falls
outside of actual consciousness what is
the implication of that actual
consciousness he says is on standing it
all together on one side it sits over
here as the imperfect moral
consciousness now Hegel the term that
he's using is unfold comme des right and
that can mean imperfect but it's
imperfect not in the sense of like
having a checklist and you just didn't
get everything on the checklist you know
like when we think about figure skaters
and they're they're skating around and
the judges bring up the cards and
somebody's like wow ten out of ten
perfect score they did every single
thing the way they're supposed to do it
right or perfect performance review the
figure skater won if we think it through
a little bit more what goes into making
something go from a 9 point 8 to a 10
you know and and how do you compare
these different performances which are
really not that that's similar to each
other except in the fact that they're
out on the ice with leotards or whatever
it is that they're wearing on and
skating around I mean what makes this
one this this performance better
objectively then this one over here and
it has to do with the other side of the
fulcrum now right the the other side of
the having been brought to its
conclusion this is an older sense of
perfection one in which you know we see
Aristotle working over and over again or
the Stoics or others when they talk
about something being perfect they mean
that it is brought to its fullest degree
of development and so our moral
consciousness might not just be
imperfect in the sense of being sinful
as opposed to holy or falling short or
you know having some bad intentions it's
not as developed as it ought to be it is
there's something missing there's a
privation of a good that ought to be
there in that moral consciousness so he
says that this is an imperfect moral
consciousness how so well there's two
modalities and these are ones that are
quite familiar to us from this section
in the previous section knowing and
willing this in and valen right so he
says with respect to its knowledge it
knows itself as a consciousness whose
knowledge and conviction are imperfect
and contingent what does that mean in
relation to duty our knowledge and
conviction are imperfect and contingent
let's think about the conviction it's
one thing to we're all familiar with
knowing what we ought to do and not
being able to get ourselves to do it
whether it be duties to ourselves like
you know
making sure that we actually do the work
that were you know we decided for
ourselves whether its duties to other
following through on a obligation that
we don't really want to fulfill duties
to in other ways right we're all
familiar with a failure of conviction
this is something that you know the
Greeks called ecclesia a lack of self
mastery and there's a lot of debate
about well is it does it really happen
you know why does a person know the good
but fail to do the good or to pursue the
good or defend the good a lot of
interesting points there to consider but
we're not going to go deep into that
let's just take it for granted that we
do in fact have this experience and we
can no notice that there's a sort of
double modality here right we can know
that our conviction is imperfect and
that it's contingent what does it mean
that it's contingent zoophilia is it
means that it might depend on other
things like some days you really feel
like following through on things other
days you don't we know that fulfilling
your duties is tougher after you've had
a long stressful day and you're hungry
then when you wake up in the morning
feeling rested and chipper so that's the
conviction part what about the knowledge
part how does that affect duty do we
really know what all of our duties are
we might be deficient with respect to
some of them we may in fact have
mistaken ideas about how people ought to
treat other people ought to treat
themselves this is a age-old problem
isn't it and human consciousness does in
fact develop towards better and better
understandings of that but every single
generation has to figure these matters
out for itself that's part of what it
means to transmit human culture and
there can be massive failures or
cultures can go into decline
along these lines as well the knowledge
that we have of our duties is in some
respect contingent it's also often
imperfect what about our willing is our
willing
imperfect and contingent yes we've
already covered that a little bit in
talking about the across yet part
notice that the Willing itself can be
somewhat reflexive he goes on a little
bit further here and he says in regard
to its willing it knows itself as a
consciousness whose purposes are
affected with sensuousness a term that
we came across before having all of
these other non-duty based inclinations
desires and drives I I want to do the
right thing and yet at the same time I
want to eat that hamburger and I can't
have both right and the hamburger really
is attractive right now this is a silly
example but you get the point here
that's something that is conceivable for
us if not necessarily for me myself at
least for remember that that character
in Popeye who is very hamburger hungry I
forget his name I think it was wimpy and
he was constantly promising people to
pay them back on Tuesday for a hamburger
today because he wanted hamburgers so
badly even after he'd made a whole bunch
of bad promises in the past that he
should have fulfilled by giving other
people hamburgers he wants that
hamburger for himself as a perfect
example of sensuousness and its impact
on the will what's the upshot of this
for Hegel he goes on and he says on
account of its unworthiness if you're
aware of just how badly off you are the
fact that your knowledge and your
willing is in some respect deficient
then you're aware of being unworthy in
relation to the pure Divine Will and he
says it cannot look on happiness as
necessary but something contingent
something that they can only expect as a
gift of grace and where does that grace
come from the holy will the as Hegel has
been calling it the master the ruler of
the world the divine lawgiver provides
us with the happiness that we enjoy now
you could take that
the picture and say well you know maybe
that's also contingent as well because
we don't understand how grace works
Hagel doesn't do this at that point
again not because Hagel is necessarily
committed to that but he's following out
the development of moral consciousness
as it works through its own
contradictions
but although its actuality is imperfect
all the same it's pure will and
knowledge hold duty to be what is
essential in the notion therefore so far
as the notion is contrasted with reality
or in thought it is perfect but the
absolute being is just this being that
is thought a being that is postulated
beyond reality it is therefore the
thought in which morally and perfect
knowledge and willing are held to be
perfect and the absolute being since it
gives full way to this imperfection
bestows happiness according to
worthiness that is according to the
merit ascribed to the imperfect moral
consciousness
here in paragraph 609 another short one
in this block of little paragraphs all
connected together we're seeing an
interesting transformation begin to take
place that is going to reach its
culmination in the following paragraph
so what is that we just saw that the
moral consciousness that we have is
imperfect right in terms of its
knowledge which also includes its
conviction as Hegel says and it's
willing and we have also at the same
time this this absolute being is he's
going to call it here the divine law
giver the ruler and an master of the
world who somehow aligns happiness and
morality or whatever it also does nature
and morality we want to oppose to each
other that we postulate that within this
being somehow that that happens so he
says though it's actuality is imperfect
the actuality of contingent real moral
consciousness he says it's pure will and
knowledge hold duty to be what is
essential and so in the notion what's
the notion it says over here on this
side of absolute being insofar as the
notion is contrasted with reality or in
thought it's perfect the concept that
McGriff and and this is in a projected
subjectivity right and other so he says
the absolute being is just this being
that is thought a being
postulated very important here as beyond
reality beyond veer click item so you
know it doesn't do any good to say oh
you know we observe that in the world
happiness and and and morality don't
coincide there's a lot of people who are
unhappy who really deserve to be happy
and there's a lot of miserable bastards
who aren't really miserable because they
they get over
and everything turns out roses for them
well that's not really an objection to
this because this is postulated and
thought beyond that reality there's a
little bit of impotence there that we're
going to talk about in a bit but let's
go on with this so he says in this
thought he says it's there for the
thought in which morally imperfect
knowledge and willing are held to be
perfect so there's a kind of perfection
in carried out by whatever we want to
call it grace the the behind-the-scenes
working of this this absolute being
there is a perfecting of our morally
imperfect knowing and willing something
helps us out so that the you know
halfway good halfway crap efforts that
we can make an understanding of things
that we have actually fulfills the
duties that were were supposed to
fulfill these pure duties so he says
these are held to be perfect the
absolute being since it gives full
weight to this imperfection bestows
happiness according to worthiness and we
just saw in the last paragraph that the
morally imperfect consciousness
understands its own unworthiness in
relation to this being of pure Duty what
Kant calls a holy will the divine being
and in at the same time this divine
being is helping it is changing it in
some way so he says it gives it gives
happiness according to worthiness that
is according to the merit ascribe to the
imperfect moral consciousness so I mean
if we want to sort of be a little
facetious here we could say that the
holy will the divine rule giver is
always looking on the bright side of
things and seeing what's not perfect but
at least on the way to perfection what
can be worked with over here on the side
of the morally imperfect consciousness
and it's it's knowledge and it's willing
it fills in the gap
so it then does bestow happiness upon it
and that happiness in a way it's not
merited but in a way it gives that is
the divine rule giver gives whatever is
needed so it could merit the happiness
this is a thought that we have to work
out a little bit more fully here
in this the moral view of the world is
completed for in the notion of the moral
self-consciousness the two aspects pure
duty and actuality are explicitly joined
in a single unity and consequently the
one like the other is expressly without
a being of its own but is only a moment
or is superseded this becomes explicit
for consciousness in the last phase of
the moral view of the world that is to
say it places pure duty in a being other
than itself that is it posits pure Duty
partly as something existing only in
thought partly as something that is not
valid in and for itself rather it is the
non moral consciousness that is held to
be perfect
equally it gives itself the character of
a consciousness whose actuality not
being in conformity with duty is
superseded and qua superseded or in the
idea of absolute being no longer
contradicts morality
here in paragraph 610 Hegel will tell us
that the moral view of the world has
been completed now it's not completely
completed we can say the German word
here is full lend it but certainly a
phase of its development has been
brought to its conclusion the moral view
of the world let's remind ourselves he's
using this veldt on shaolong this
intuition of how the world in fact is
but we've seen of course that it is much
more than merely an intuitive grasp on
things it's sort of a pervasive
comprehension that is approaching what
we call the notion the became so he says
in the notion the notion the beginneth
of the moral self-consciousness we have
these two aspects that we've been
juggling back and forth pure duty
morality and actuality could be nature
happiness the will as we actually do in
fact will it experience it he says these
are explicitly joined in a single unity
and consequently the one like the other
both of them are without a being of
their own but are only a moment they
only really as we found now through
through pursuing this exist in relation
to each other they have their meaning in
relation to each other so he says that
they are superseded their alcohol burn
right this is telling us that an
important transition has taken place
because remember Alf hey bunk is this
this fundamental notion running
throughout the Hegelian dialectic it
means something like surpassing and yet
preserving the essential moments
integrated within a larger whole it's
not merely leaving the previous shape of
consciousness behind but rather
reintegrating what is important what has
been achieved within them so pure duty
and actuality reality if you like these
are both moments for the moral
consciousness
for the notion of moral consciousness
now he goes on and he tells us that this
becomes explicit for consciousness in
the last phase of the moral view of the
world now what is he saying there think
about the fact that we are not in the
last paragraph of the section of the
moral view of the world we hit we're at
paragraph 610 and there are actually 615
paragraphs well we're at paragraph 615
and when we finish up that section and
move into the dissembling sword
duplicity so what should this tell us we
are not completely done with the moral
view of the world it has not been made
totally explicit at this point but we
have arrived at a very important turning
point well what is this he says it
places pure duty this is something we
realized in the previous paragraphs in a
being other than itself moral
consciousness places pure Duty not
within itself not within the
uncompromising universe but in some
other subjectivity in an other and a
capital o other if we want to get you
know Lakhani and about this right that
we can in fact relate ourselves to in
some way we can conceive of it as the
divine lawgiver as the ruler of the
universe we can think of it as that
which gives us the grace to improve
ourselves and which helps us you know
merit some happiness we can think of it
in whatever way we want but it's
something different than ourselves it's
not just us so he says it posits pure
duty as something existing only where in
thought now in whose thought in the
thought of the thinker out there
thinking whatever thoughts God thinks no
in our thought that being that other out
there doing what it's doing being a pure
we will is in a certain way only for us
so he says it's partly as something
that's not valid in and for itself we
are starting to realize maybe were valid
in and for ourselves well maybe not
right because we're imperfect but that
being out there is not something valid
in and for itself and then he says
something really startling here rather
it's the non moral consciousness is the
assumption non-moral that is held to be
perfect that's the thought that Hegel
doesn't unpack at this point that we'll
have to consider more in the paragraphs
yet to come what about the other side he
says equally it gives itself the
character of a consciousness whose
actuality this is the real world
consciousness the person I am who I'm
conscious of being not being in
conformity with duty I'm very aware of
my in my own life that I'm often not in
conformity with duty and I'll bet that
you are too is superseded again we see
this Alf fable right here it's alcohol
burn right and as superseded or in the
idea of absolute being no longer
contradicts morality so we've got a pure
duty that really exists only for some
actual being that can recognize its own
imperfection in relation to this ideal
that exists only in pure thought and on
the other side we have ourselves as the
miserable people that we are imperfect
conscious of our imperfection but we're
being brought to a higher level by being
somehow related to this being that we're
thinking for which pure Duty would not
be a challenge the way it is for us
Hegel says that this brings the
development of the moral consciousness
to a certain fulfillment is it finished
no so we have five more paragraphs yet
come in which we'll see how it continues
to develop but this is a very important
turning point isn't it because we're
working here now with a more fully
fleshed out notion of moral
self-consciousness
you